so fearing this story is sounding 100%
like coke cravings Korean Britney Spears
brings back the dramatic tone just try
to listen to this with any hint of
seriousness a thousand nos is about a
rare nuff who comes once in a generation
of a nod a scrunch would do anything to
kill a madam not even forget his fears
of the tattoo did she know that she's
madam na okay I'm sure Shyamalan is
hearing this really intense dramatic
story but to the rest of the world oh we
can hear is a thousand ARF
we're not the madam not kill a matter of
the madam nor herself she know that
she's a madam cough once in a generation
of carbs I would give anything if the
twist of this movie was that the entire
time it was Pinky and the brain tried to
take over the world literally every
single problem would be fixed if they
just do that twist
it's a Warner Brothers movie make it
happen speaking of which the master
writer himself is told that his writing
is going to change the world and give
inspiration I shit you not here to the
future president this boy become leader
of this country and begin a movement of
great change but also yeah gets even
better
his ideas will be so dangerous that
someone will eventually take his life
because of them and yet he still chooses
to write the story sacrificing himself
not only for his art before the world
Wow
is it windy on that egotistical high
horse that you built for yourself I mean
Christ you can see his boner growing
with every praising word he will speak
of you and you
your book will be the seeds of many of
his great though be the seeds of change
mmm now that's a messy story so Giamatti
is told that rufio's mother will only
tell the rest of the story if she can
see him like a child you have to make us
see you as a child innocent so I can't
even just watch
ah but tell her it's a beautiful story I
don't wanna get home are there are there
any parts that might be good to hear
don't dog Duke we should do the guy okay
so let's say this represents the world
of sanity and this represents the edge
of sanity and this represents the world
of insanity you would be on Mars you're
so friggin gone because we have no idea
where the hell you are to come up with a
scene this goddamn bonkers honey what
the hell is going on is this what you do
with all your oscar-nominated actors
make them look like they're jerking off
sideways while peeing like a dog that's
not acting like a child that's acting
like three lobotomies were given to you
in maple syrup why are you so the nerve
can't say anything about her world for
reasons but that's okay because she
touches her ear to answer yes or no
questions as that doesn't count for
reasons so there's a symbolist a
guardian a healer and a guild he's
supposed to find in order to help her
and before you say anything yes
this simple bedtime story is this
goddamn complicated as a frickin D&D
game do you know who the symbolist or
interpreter is I don't know let's roll
the dice to find out so he goes to the
crossword guy and his increasingly
strange son just picture this Cheryl
Bucks is supposed to make you feel happy
I feel sad like that time you forgot to
pick me up at school
are we in Wonderland he finds the others
as well and takes them to a naked cut-up
lady he's keeping in his shower this
raises no concerns interpreter will tell
us what to do nine letters
is the word essential I thought I
thought that was weird
yeah really that's weird
you're using a crossword puzzle to
predict the future in front of a naked
woman who's been kidnapped by the
sideways guy and that's running weird
what I said the boy thing is even by
bedtime story standards there's
practically no action in any of this I
mean did Shyamalan actually read this to
his kids every night and then they sat
around the shower for a bit doing
crosswords as mr. cheap turd the
apartments for a fifth time to talk to
even more people no kids that story
doesn't have nearly enough references to
another story to make it interesting
this is a bedtime story for a new
generation that needs us working so he
apparently can see the scrunt by walking
backwards and looking in the mirror why
because it's less complicated than doing
jumping jacks and looking through a
fruit loop just get used to nothing
being explained the scrunch scares him
away but to be fair you were asking Paul
Giamatti to protect you what you think
what's gonna happen in fact you saved
him the first time you really thought
this was the guy who was gonna be on top
of things
there is no originality left in the
world mr. Heep so they work on a new
strategy scrunt will hide unless he
canopied in his environment doesn't that
go without saying he'll hide unless he
can't hide something decide to throw a
party to distract this grunt yeah oh
he's good to throw other people flies in
there as we're realizing getting closer
and closer to the end that this really
should have been called lady in the
water she barely does a frigging thing
what they should have called it as
whispering because that's all anybody
does it's not you sorry I can hear
myself finding your purpose you haven't
written anything the rest of this land
will grow up in a home turn it up turn
it up so they wait for the Eagle to come
and get her as apparently nobody in the
party would notice that but hey if they
don't notice a grass dog attacking a
woman to dragging her into the woods I
guess they
notice that either oh by the way a grass
dog attacks aren't drags her into the
woods oh no this is terrible what should
we do more crosswords no I don't know
but big shock they start to ask what if
this is all a little crazy why are you
so certain that I am the interpreter and
they are the guild
I ask someone what kind of person would
be so arrogant to presume to know the
intention of another human being who was
put this young girl's life in jeopardy
what heartless demon who gives points of
view on art has doomed mankind for all
eternity Oh The Critic only he prays
Shyamalan I mean any random writers of
their genius but no he had to point out
the fault of movies like signs I mean
any random story this is also obviously
about Shyamalan I mean Shyamalan I mean
shaman I mean you if you were Shyamalan
look at this he writes the critics so
one dimensionally that he actually
confuses real life for a movie it's
precisely the moment where the mutation
or beast will attempt to kill an
unlikable side character and stories
where there has been no prior cursing
nudity killing the unlikable character
will narrowly escape you may even be
given a humorous moment to allow the
audience to feel good this is really
hard it's a really hard for me thank you
I just that's all they are that's all
critics are it's literally just my life
is a movie everything is connected to
movie I am robot I charge and hate
everything there is no personal vendetta
going on at all it is about you know
personal artists at home it is not about
one individual person who probably is in
this film somewhere I mean I can't see
him at all it's just too subtle but
maybe he's in the movie
I'm sorry this is so a profession I
should stay serious that won't happen
again I like just get out a little bit
more okay okay what happen again I
promise mm-hmm
so after that stellar satire criticism
really SNL worthy they start to wonder
if anyone else could possibly be the
interpreter the hands of the guild will
be needed plus two others it is a
ceremony of seven sisters sisters the
guild is winging touch together with
their hearts is one to bring strength to
the moment I stroke you will need a man
who has no secrets and one whose opinion
is highly respected as with
people at home you are not stoned you
are not high you are seeing this
correctly a little boy with incredible
detail is predicting the future of an
ancient civilization by staring and
cereal boxes is he going to see a cookie
crumb cuckoo for cocoa puffs when
captain crunches neck oh snap crackle
and pop and it'll be almost tarry this
wall be over in moments now on to the
spice rack well I will predict the
second coming of Jesus oh I just came a
bit I read it wrong I thought it said
she will lead a ceremony of Seven
Sisters to bring strength to the moment
but it really just said cinnamon toast
crunch it turns out giamatti has to be
the healer because well symbolically it
ties to his family and that dead horse
is so kicked you can see the nike symbol
indented into it it of course brings her
back to life as the big Shyamalan twist
is finally revealed imagine
oh my god it takes place at The Cove
wait I already knew that why'd you cut
to that what the hell's the twist years
ago
Reggie's the Guardian wow I didn't know
cliff Mills could service twists now I
mean up whoo you really got me uh to
look at the movie a whole different way
now and then apparently these things
come out
oh um crude your ass is grass the Eagles
are coming
the Eagles are coming and no kidding
that's the ending yeah
the Eagle picks her up and it just stops
even giamatti has a look in his face
like that's it
are you kidding me my two-minute cameo
in Downton Abbey was worth more of my
time than ass people I know of the
happening is fun but where else can you
see a narf outrunning ass grunt with
Paul Giamatti waving his leg and
touching himself in front of two women
helped by a guy who can predict the
future through crosswords who gave birth
to a prophet who can read mythologies
that are part of a complete breakfast
with the critic who dares call this all
insane portrayed as the bad guy with
tree halls beating up grass stains with
teeth while giant eagle picks up a
whispering tart whose only job was to
tell a person to write a book and the
twist centers around the guy we saw only
for two minutes in the opening how can
this not be a masterpiece of madness
complete and total entertaining madness
so to show my appreciation for this
incredible experience I am finally gonna
give Shyamalan exactly what he wants
you summoned sit down Sharma
all right
tell me about your genius method in
making this film
really
well I was trying to get across how
creative artists are always kept down by
cynicism ah so the woman's story
actually represent the artists story
yeah I never knew if I made that clear
enough and am I correct in thinking that
the character of the critic is a subtle
jab to people who don't understand your
work exactly you don't think that came
off too strong do you of course not I
thought it was downplayed actually so I
wanted to get across that all the people
in the world who criticize they're the
real death of dreams and how did you
come up with those incredible names it
sounds like it came from a language
that's existed for here that was my
intention
you see I'm a big fan of creating other
worlds and other worlds have different
sounding names so I said to myself what
sounds weird and otherworldly an art you
just hear that word and immediately you
think a beautiful woman
not